sylvia jeanjacquot pendant les 18 mois
durant lesquels vous avez partagé la
cavale de jacques mesrine
j'allais au cinéma vous allez dans les
plus grands restaurants mais ce que vous
allez dans les boîtes de nuit à paris
non mais allons en sicile en italie
partout luxembourg une forme mais papa
part et pourquoi pas pareil parce qu'à
paris c'était trop dangereux
ah bon ils allaient au cinéma avec vous
sur les champs elysées dans les
restaurants bars les restaurants se
promener partout sauf en discothèque
palais disposait pour envoyer des
descentes de flics ont enfin c'est un
peu gênant par rapport à beaucoup de
choses par rapport à nous d'aller mieux
éviter quand même alors meriva et publié
un bouquin qui s'appelait l'instinct de
mort vous en publiant il s'appelle
l'instinct de vie qui est extraordinaire
parce que ça se lit comme on dit
bêtement comme un rebond le pire c'est
que c'est vrai et puis en plus
l'histoire est réellement arrivé dans
l'histoire comme ans qui nie en cours
porte de clignancourt le 2 novembre 79
vous êtes avec mérine dans une bmw d'un
seul coup il ya un camion bâché darren
devant vous la bâche se relève il ya
quatre policiers qui font feu sur mairie
n'est aussi sûr bon sang pourquoi sur
vous je ne sais pas on ne l'a jamais si
je crois que c'était pour éviter ce
genre de choses pour qu'il reste un
témoin quelqu'un pour dire ce qui
s'était passé
bon je veux dire après on a quand même
tiré au mas tire une balle dans la tête
juste au moment où j'ai tourné la page
je vais en attente et quand même de
m'achever une fois que tout était
terminé je vois jacques hémond petit
caniche aimons vraiment ma sortir ou
rentrer la voiture
qu'est-ce qui vous aviez qualcomm comme
blessures j'en ai partout j'avais la
tête explosée je suis bordelais gauche
je vais j'avais plus de poigne et je
l'on m'a fait une greffe osseuse rabe
est en danger un pompage ici sont
enchaînés l'artère claqué l'avait
numéral claquette
donc on a fait un pontage en fait on
voulait me tuer moi là certainement
probablement parce que je dois déjà dans
une bm c'était très très large comme ça
ouais on est espacée comme ça les
fauteuils sont très larges
il était à 4 mètres devant nous quatre
c'est quand même d'autant plus qu'après
quand tout était terminé mais qui est
arrivé de mon côté qui m'attire une
balle en plus apprendre à présenter à la
tête un bon d'accord carrément alors ça
c'est le début du lit qu'après alors y'a
un flash back on voit votre rencontre
vous travaillez dans un bar à pigalle
quand elle était amenée à travailler
dans ce bar à pigalle à prix cassé la
première fois je mettais les pieds j'ai
travaillé dans différents bars dans
paris est bon à l'époque y avait
quelques problèmes aux anciens mais pas
real comme je trouve et je cherchais du
travail j'en trouvais pas une amie qui
m'a dit que c'est un super mec en pensez
la salle et je faisais quoi barmen et
barmaids et un jour vous avez vu arriver
jack meyrink était arrivé en cavale qui
venait de ces vallées de la santé qui
étaient déguisées
vous saviez pas qui c'était non pas du
tout 1 nous c'était un coup de foudre
tout de suite où étaient conservés au
premier regard tout de suite vous avez
su que c'était lui l'homme de votre vie
peut-être pas tout de suite tout de
suite dont il ya très rapidement qu'est
ce qui vous a dit quand ils vous avez vu
comme ça la première fois au derrière le
vin ou comprend rien il m'a dit bonjour
et je demandais ce qu'il prenait élus
d'en faire un verbe ouais voilà ça
commence l'histoire saab c'est assez
incroyable ils vous demandent de [ __ ]
toutes vos affaires en l'air l'air de
rien regarder emilie va vous amener en
italie et alors là il ya plein de scènes
qui sont comme un film de belmondo ouais
c'est à dire qu'à un moment vous arrivez
à la frontière italienne
il ya un embouteillage à la douane et il
fait là il fait la circulation il ya un
camion un gros camion qui s'est renversé
qui louche tout passage ouais c'est la
circulation ça il est sorti l'a fait
reculer toutes ces voitures voilà
toujours avec sa casquette sur la tête
non plus une autre fois l'aéroport il ya
sa photo avec marc est recherchée piller
ce mec là me ressemble ouais c'est photo
de lui tous les déguisements imaginables
vous aviez peur quand vous passiez la
douane comme ça avec lui un non pas du
tout une fois vous êtes allé faire une
affiche avec marc et wanted aussi avec
sap est la mienne et la scène tout
allait louer une maison à j'ai un
brigadier en retraite après ça c'est
quand il a voulu acheter l'appartement
c'est bizarre comme cette idée de
vouloir absolument acheter un
appartement parce qu'une fois qu'ils
avaient l'argent de la rançon
lièvre vous auriez pu partir en devez
partir partez le vanneau jean bouhey ont
quitté la france au parti pour l'italie
de l'est serait retouches et le coin des
yeux les lèvres puis bon je me disais
bonne chance prochaine et est numéro
racontez nous comment il voulait se
marier avec vous ils voulaient braquer
va faire braquer par ses amis la mairie
du viiie arrondissement et nous marier
sous la force avec ses calibres comme il
dit c'est vous et vous soyez marié
parent pension affichent une hausse que
nous venons s'était pas peur de se dire
que ça pouvait être que sous la menace
de
de ses rivales vert très étonnant et en
jeans et baskets parce qu'après ça
l'état les partis rapport mais ce qui
est très étonnant dans votre bouquin
c'est que ces raconte effectivement ça
fait est enfin comme ça ça fait très
aventure gendarmes et voleurs quoi quand
il parle de le lièvre il dit on va
kidnapper le fils et après il dit en
donnant mais le bégaiement récupérera
pas la rançon est pour quand la fille de
l'appel vieux festival du livre
c'est ce qu'il a fait alors on a comparé
mérine
cartouche à manderen robin des bois en
fait quand on lit enfin quand on sait
qu'il était quand même quand on lit
votre bouquin quand même il a pas que ce
côté-là redresseur de torts il a quand
même un côté un peu bof quand ils
racontent pas ses journées à regarder la
télé en critiquant que ce soir là ils
ont ces chantres de dîner à la maison de
rester d'un canal t edward et sa télé
n'importe quoi pourvu que ce soit la
télé qui marche
en fait on s'aperçoit que l'ennemi
public numéro 1 était assez petit
bourgeois finalement oui c'est long mais
c'est exact c'est la vérité alors il ya
des crises comme ça comment ça se fait
qu'il a ses crises ses colères mais
c'est terrible mais ce n'est vraiment
pas même s'agir par exemple il y avait
quelque chose à la télé on et se trouve
qu'ils sont non et l'appel mesrine ont
lieu devant les saguenéens
alors que les larves horriblement ou
alors tu en plus si on dit un mot qui
n'est pas correct sur lui arrive déclic
aux lèvres en table après le type de la
télé nation le point noir il veut tuer
le mec de la télé après pas le tuer mon
fils mais crise il est bon on était très
en colère les boulevards qu'est ce
qu'ils voulaient lui faire à philippe
ouvert parce qu'il ya dans votre livre
sera fait je me dit qu'il veut avait
donné une raclée à philippe bas il avait
dit que s'il avait un petit moment à
perdre il lui en faudrait une dans le
crâne en moto vite fait en moto vite
fait oui pourquoi parce qu'il n'aimait
pas le petit théâtre de bouvard
parce que je prends car avant que
jacques ces dates de la santé dit encore
détenus les cris des saletés sur lui
arrêtez pas content il ya des choses
qu'on a retrouvé les bandes magnétiques
on a retrouvé rue belliard après après
la mort bien non quand on a fouillé le
studio après la mort de jacques
vous avez lire ses complices quand même
quand il dit je vais aller voir le juge
petit pour lui pour lui donner une leçon
vous dit tu as raison mon coussin faut
être méchant pour la ddiss a quand même
en vous lavant temps des magasins vous
l'avez entendu la 4 heures je vous
l'avais écouté c'est sûr si parce que
l'époque elle est passée devant la cour
d'assises ne sert qu'à 7
vous avez vraiment dit ça c'est pas très
bien la choisir pour ilaris n'allait pas
le tuer il allait lui une correction est
dû prendre ces dossiers vous pensez
vraiment qu'ils voulaient pas le tuer
alors on apprendra motifs comment mérine
s'est fait attraper quoi cette histoire
de la r5 et une d'un roman policier pour
pour inventer ça je le dis est faux
c'est à dire que lui en fait il avait
1h14 la police parle d'une r5 son copain
qu'ils aient voté leur cadeau garde la
r14 a pris la place à charlie bauer qui
gardèrent 14
la police parle de r5 et lui se met à
parler de r5 voilà donc la police se
rend compte que si parle lui de r5 c'est
qu'il avait gardé la r14 aucun n'avait
gardé c'est comme ça qui se fait
attraper et c'est déjà été dit ça ou
c'est la première fois qu'on le dit
c'est parce qu'on me semble aussi la
première fois pour lui sera présent dans
indécent parce que comme j'ai jamais vu
la presse
moi je n'ai jamais parlé ça fait très
très peur parce que les free compte
aujourd'hui qu'ils avaient filé charlie
bauer mons avait pas l'histoire de mer
ce week end pascal la voiture était
déclarée et donc ils sont remontés par
sa part plein de choses m'enfin bon
aussi paraît-il que lui charlie il avait
été balancé par quelqu'un qui avait un
ami
dans l'aquarelle vous avez été acquitté
j'ai passé deux ans en prison
vous avez porté plainte parce qu'en fait
ils n'étaient pas les flics dépend
légitime défense quand
non non pas du tout même pavé cuisine
ont donc il y avait déjà pas vraiment de
raison de tirer sur lui encore moins sur
vous donc vous avez commencé par porter
plainte
oui ça nous a été acquitté est-ce que ça
a été un deal entre entre votre avocat
et la justice en disant nous on retire
notre plainte et puis on se dira quand
j'ai été acquitté su passer aux assises
le procès a duré huit jours j'ai été
acquitté
j'avais plusieurs inculpations de recel
j'ai eu un non lieu
oui mais ça n'a rien à voir avec la
plainte parce que la plainte jettent on
a toujours essayé de faire avec m jura
mis ce qu'il fallait pour et à chaque
fois c'est pas possible
non parce qu'ils disent que c'était le
doyen des juges d'instruction j'avais vu
que d'après le procès-verbal du
commissaire broussard ganic rémy délit
ah ben non alors donc là il a arrêté là
c'est tout le commissaire beau samedi
nous sommes descendu du camion nous
avons encerclé la voiture nous avons
compté jusqu'à 3 nous avons sucrier
police ou les mains rendez-vous et
croyant coin voilà enfin voilà procès
verbal savez que c'est pas vrai ça ah
oui ça bouge tout à fait vous savez
qu'ils ont tiré directement directement
il en tirer comme un lapin quoi oui
c'est voilà il faut exécuter non
liquidés ali quitté j'ai 100 milles à
combien pour la voir ils étaient 95
c'était deux bouts c'était comme ça donc
leur fusil pointé son move et la chose
en bois comme ça on va il était debout
et campings français ils le savent et
lucas se faire attraper
oui mais je veux dire bon il ya tous et
il ya toujours un jeu 10 rebonds il
savait que si on le prenait on lui
mettre une balle dans la tête je me
disais oui mais je veux dire il ya
toujours gardé quand même toujours
l'espoir parce que je veux dire il avait
prévu l'appartement au cas où la
chirurgie esthétique je veux dire tout
était prévu jeudi rebond même si savez
c'est garder comme l'espoir de pouvoir
partir et de passer au travers
c'est extraordinaire c'est que ça arrive
juste au moment où vous aviez partir
comme dans les films
alors il ya un truc qui est fou c'est
qu'on vous a rendu les bijoux qui
avaient été achetés qui vous a été
offert par par jacques avec une opinion
de l'art ensemble le liège comment ça se
fait ça a été acheté en france on se dit
bon moi il m'a fait un des bijoux j'ai
pas regardé avec quoi vous les avez eue
après ses bijoux
oui et le livre lui a pas demandé mais
moi je ne sais pas avec quoi chappuis en
c1 les bijoux - je ne sais pas si c'est
l'argent de la rançon c'est ça l'est pas
mais dans vos sims qui est ainsi vous
n'avez pas de remords pas drôle
si vous l'aimez pas de repentir non non
plus n'ont plus rien on fait quoi
maintenant
maintenant je reste et sans travailler
et l'acteur en ce moment ce n'est pas
nul ami qui vient d'ouvrir un bar ya
deux mois et pour l'instant mon comme l
avait personne je la dépanne en
attendant nous vous tenez un bar pour le
moment non ce n'est pas un badge détail
une amie fâcherie barmaid chez une amie
qui viennent prendre un bain et la sage
la dépanne en ce moment elle a ouvert ya
deux mois j'ai pu d'histoire avec la
pollution non si c'était à refaire vous
feriez la même chose oui c'est
aujourd'hui il en valait la peine
il valait à peine d'être connue jeudi en
même sachant les suites je dirais non je
regrette pas même si maintenant je suis
borg handicap estropiés tout ce qu'on
veut je sois trackpad salle un bruit
c'est bon mais je vais me brûle en
valait vraiment la tester quand même
quelqu'un d'ouvert
je suis désolé mais en dehors d'être
ennemis publics numéro un le personnage
dans la vie c'était quelqu'un de bien et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude
abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus